HBO's Game of Thrones prequel series
House of the Dragons is bringing fans
back over 200 years before the events of
the main series with a new teaser for
this prequel recently released we've got
some questions for starters was that
Dragonstone and what's with that new
Stark by the time Game of Thrones begins
there are no more folks of old Valyrian
blood left on Westeros Daenerys and her
brother viserys are wandering essos and
Exile after the events of Robert's
Rebellion the new house of the Dragon
trailer presents a very different state
of affairs with more platinum-headed
Dragon Riders skulking around then you
can shake a flaming sword at what gives
in the Deep westerosi past long before
the time of the Mad King heiress and
Robert's fateful Rebellion there were a
lot more valyrians running around
Westeros and they weren't all targaryens
either in the mass Exodus from essos
after the Doom of Valeria two prominent
Valyrian families actually conquered
Westeros the targaryens and the
valerians the letter of which has died
out by the time Game of Thrones begins
at the time of House of the Dragon
however the valerians are still very
much on the scene and will play a
central role in the Targaryen Civil War
to come marked by their silver hair
expect the valerians to play The Game of
Thrones hard in the new series since
there aren't any left by the time the
flagship Series starts you can imagine
how that turns out in the new teaser
trailer to House of the Dragon audiences
witnessed some familiar names bending
the knee to King viserys the first
Targaryen I reckon stock I call this
valarian I foreign super fans will
likely remember that eddard Stark's
father was named Rickard Stark but the
record seen in this trailer is alive
some 200 years before Game of Thrones
even starts so we're talking a totally
different Rick here characters in the
world of Game of Thrones tend to name
their children after deceased family
members and the targaryens are no
different King viserys the first
Targaryen sits upon the Iron Throne at
the start of House of the Dragons fans
who closely recall season one of Game of
Thrones we'll note that daenerys's older
brother viserys shares the same
distinguished moniker this makes King
viserys the first Targaryen Danny and
viserys's distant ancestor living some
200 years before any of the final
generation of targaryens are born
Targaryen family members have a tendency
to slip into some Disturbing Behavior
but it seems viserys the first doesn't
fall into that specific category the
show's official page describes viserys
the first as a kind and decent King
before issuing a stark reminder in the
world of Game of Thrones good men don't
necessarily make for good Kings when you
play the game of thrones you
will you die
there is no middle ground
based on the teaser trailer and what we
know about westerosi history already
House of the Dragon seems to dive into
the conflict that arises as viserys the
first grapples with his brother's
ambition even as he names his firstborn
child The Heir Apparent to the iron
throne in the new trailer for House of
the Dragon a familiar and ornate War
Room in Dragonstone should have caught
the attention of eagle-eyed Game of
Thrones fans this particular meeting
spot in Game of Thrones hosts Stannis
Baratheon for several seasons but the
heavily fortified city is left vacant
after stannis's defeat and is easily
reoccupied by Daenerys Targaryen after
she makes her Voyage from essos fans
familiar with Game of Thrones lore will
remember that before Robert's Rebellion
The Fortress of Dragonstone was part of
the crownlands under the Paramount
lordship of the Targaryen Kings by
tradition The Fortress was held by the
Targaryen Crown Prince rhaegar at the
time of Robert's Rebellion that's why
Daenerys Stormborn is born on said
stormy Island she was secreted away to
that stronghold while her brother mother
was out Prosecuting eris's war and
fathering Jon Snow with lyanna Stark
Stannis is actually the first and the
last Baratheon to hold Dragonstone so
what military Mischief might the Dragon
Riders be planning around the table this
go around notably the island of
Dragonstone is adjacent to the island of
driftmark seat of house Valerian if a
conflict is to break out between the two
old Valyrian houses these two islands
are likely to be at the center of it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite television shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
foreign